hoffe Sie sind alle gut und gesund in
dieses neue Jahr gekommen würd gerne
Anton Hofreiter gleich zu Beginn Fragen
ähm 100.000ende Trecker LKW haben große
Teile des Landes lahm gelegt wie groß
ist ihr Verständnis für das was wir da
gesehen haben na auf der einen Seite
muss man schon Verständnis haben nicht
man darf eins nicht vergessen das ist ja
al nicht so besonders geschickt
kommuniziert worden oder eigentlich kaum
kommuniziert worden es kam ziemlich
überfallartig
über die Betroffenen auch der and dann
kommt halt dazu dass insbesondere das
habe ich ja schon öfters angemerkt der
Kanzler im Grunde überhaupt nicht
erklärt in welcher Lage wir in Europa in
Deutschland sind dass wir eben in einer
sehr sehr schwierigen Lage sind es ist
von ihnen gerade angesprochen worden wir
haben Krieg in Europa wir sehen dass die
Ukraine immer stärker unter Druck kommt
die gerade im Moment uns alle verteidigt
wir sehen dass sich Putin drauf
vorbereitet weitere Länder anzugreifen
viele Experten befürchten dass in
wenigen Jahren ein Angriff aufs Baltikum
gibt was es dann eine massive Auswirkung
des Krieges bedeuten würde und all das
in dieser dramatischen Lage halt
irgendwie alles so wabern zu lassen und
nicht zu erklären dann kam noch dazu das
Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
dass die CDU CSU erstritten hat und
damit sehr erfolgreich war und in all
der
Situation letztendlich die Dinge so
wabern zu lassen kan irgendwie verstehen
aber ich meine sind wir ehrlich der
Kompromiss sie haben ja die Zahlen
selber schon angesprochen der jetzt
zustande kommen ist der Kompromiss ist
einer der wo man eigentlich vernünftig
damit leben kann alle Seiten und ich
glaube man muss halt einfach deutlich
machen in diesen schwierigen Zeiten geht
halt nichtmer alles es geht heute
nichttimmer alles was sich jeder wünscht
natürlich kann man sich das weiter
wünschen aber wie gesagt es ist halt
nicht mehr möglich okay also sie würden
sagen den den den Bauern geht nach Hause
euch geht's gut genug manchen Bauern
geht's schlecht und aber vielen Bauern
geht's auch gut das Sagen zumindestens
die Zahlen ich meine es sagt der
Bauernverband selber sie haben es gerade
vorgelesen ja sind und des Weiteren muss
man halt
sagen es ist wie gesagt halt eine
schwierige Zeit und in dieser
schwierigen Zeit die Pflegekräfte
haben harte Zeiten erlebt äh die Ärzte
haben harte Zeiten erlebt es ganz viele
Menschen mit geringerem Einkommen
aufgrund der Inflation erleben extrem
harte Zeiten und in dieser Situation
kann der Staat halt nmer allen alles
sozusagen recht machen und wie gesagt
ungeschickt kommuniziert
überfallartig reden wir gleich drüber
sie sie beklagen das sozusagen
führungsschche Herr Wendorf geht's Ihnen
so gut und warum dann diese Proteste was
ist das Thema bei diesen Protesten also
vom Grundsatz her haben wir erstens bei
den Unternehmensergebnissen sehr hohe
Differenzierung wenn ich in meinem
Bundesland reinschaue wenn wir in das
Vorjahr die Zahlen aus dem
Wirtschaftsjahr 23 liegen uns noch nicht
vor wenn ich da reinschaue 45 000 €
Unternehmensgewinn plus Lohnkosten dann
kann sich jeder deutlich machen ich muss
aus diesen 45 000 € die Lohnkosten
begleichen und Kredittilgung die sind
daraus auch zu teilen ist da nicht viel
übrig bleibt ich glaube eine öffentliche
Hand könnte mit solchen Zahlen gar nicht
kalkulieren also da wir schauen uns
gleich mal auch dieses ganze
subventionssystem mal ein bisschen
genauer an weil es spannend ist aber
würd gerne urela Weidenfeld vorher
fragen politisch her Hofreiter hat's
gerade schon angedeutet er sagt es war
übersetzt grottenschlecht kommuniziert
würden sie auch so sehen ich glaube es
war nicht nur grottenschlecht
kommuniziert es ist auch grottten
schlecht gemacht wenn man sich eben
überlegt unabhängig jetzt mal von der
materiellen Ausstattung
landwirtschaftlicher Betriebe was
passiert wenn man einer Gruppe sagt
Kinder wir können uns nicht mehr alles
leisten
216000 260 000 Betriebe sollen ein
großen Teil dieses wir können uns nicht
mehr alles leisten sollen dafür dann
gerade stehen wie wäre das es gibt
ungefähr die Bundeswehr hat ungefähr 260
000 Angestellte also für Soldaten
Angestellte öffentlich Bedienstete wenn
man hingehen würde und sagen würde wir
müssen sparen wir können uns nicht mehr
alles leisten wie wär es denn wenn wir
den Bundeswehr Angestellten zu 2 oder 3%
ihres Einkommens abzugeben die würden
auch nicht hungern dann dann zurecht
würden die sagen so geht es nicht wir
werden nicht fair behandelt wir werden
nicht gerecht behandelt das ist nicht
fair und ich glaube dass das haben wir
bisher noch nicht besprochen die Frage
ist es fair eine Berufsgruppe einer
Berufsgruppe des
aufzuürden aufzulasten diese allgemeine
Erkenntnis wir können nicht mehr alles
bezahlen da ist glaube ich die Antwort
und deshalb das erklärt ja vielleicht
auch auch weshalb sich so viele mit den
Bauern solidarisieren das ist ja nicht
zu erwarten wir wer kennen schon einen
Bauern oder wer 90% der deutschen sagen
das ist in Ordnung die finden das in
Ordnung und die finden es in Ordnung
weil sie den Eindruck haben es ist eben
nicht nicht gut kommuniziert worden und
es ist auch keine fare Entscheidung
gewesen und beides ist glaube ich etwas
wo man wenn man einer Regierung ohnehin
kritisch gegenüber steht und sagt die
machen das handwerklich nicht wirklich
gut wo man sich dann fragt
wahrscheinlich sind wir dann die
nächsten und dann sieht man eben man
muss nur laut genug auf die Straße gehen
und sagen wir machen das nicht mit dann
knicken die schon irgendwie ein und
gehen wieder damit nach Hause das war
beim gebäudeenergiegesetz so das war bei
der Wohnungsbauförderung in Z gasumlage
so bei der gasumlage so äh und wenn man
den Eindruck hat erstens sie machen es
falsch zweitens sie sagen dann nicht wir
haben verstanden sondern sie sagen wir
gehen noch mal damit nach Hause und
kommen dann mit was anderem wieder dann
hat man am Ende eben nicht nur in der
Landwirtschaft das Gefühl das ist nicht
fair das ist nicht gut gemacht sondern
man hat eben insgesamt das Gefühl
Politik ist nicht fair sie ist schlecht
gemacht und sie nutzt am Ende selbst
wenn man Herrn Hofreiter zustimmt und
sagt wir haben Herausforderung an am am
Bein die wir eben nicht mit dem üblichen
weiter so bewältigen können selbst dann
selbst wenn man das anerkennt sagt man
dann wir sind nicht einverstanden dass
es falsch wie es läuft darf ich mal
fragen Hofreiter wie kommt es zu so
einer Entscheidung es ist ja
zwischenzeitlich der Eindruck entstanden
selbst der zuständige
Landwirtschaftsminister Jim östemir
wusste nichts
davon wie kommt zu so einer Entscheidung
wer sitzt da mit wem zusammen wird wird
er damit einbezogen ruft man den an und
sagt ch komm mal kurz rüber wir müssen
mit dir reden und dann vielleicht mal
mit einem
bauernverbandsvertreter
sprechen wem auch immer sagen wie wie
läuft sowas im Kern läuft sowas unter
den Spitzen der Beteiligten also in dem
Fall Olaf Scholz Christian Lindner und
Robert habbeck und natürlich ihren
Beraterinnen und Beratern aber was
natürlich oh ohne den zuständigen
Minister ohne natürlich wird der über
bestimmte Dinge informiert aber am Ende
sozusagen werden solche Entscheidungen
in der Spitze gefällt und er hat ja auch
deutlich gemacht dass er am Ende die
Entscheidung nicht klug fand aber der
der redet nicht mit bei dieser
Entscheidung das war der Vorschlag
sozusagen dieser drei er redet mit aber
er entscheidet es nicht sondern es war
der Vorschlag dieser drei und am Ende
muss man halt sagen ist ja auch ein
Kompromiss gefunden worden der vor dem
ursprünglichen sozusagen sehr stark
abweicht und was halt überhaupt nicht
stimmt ist dass nur eine
Bevölkerungsgruppe sozusagen betroffen
ist von den Kürzungen sondern wenn Sie
sich anschauen dass allein im klimafond
12 Milliarden gekürzt werden wo ganze
Reihe von Maßnahmen finanziert worden
wären deshalb sind der ganze Reihe
getroffen und
deshalb aber noch mal also sie sprechen
es gerade an E-Autos Wärmepumpen das
halbe Land und das ist ja das
eigentliche Thema weiß ja gar nicht mehr
was eigentlich gerade Sache ist und dann
steht da oben auf der Bühne wie neulich
Jim östemir in Berlin man hat das Gefühl
der weiß auch nicht was Sache ist doch
man weiß schon was Sache ist aber die
Sache ist halt sozusagen relativ
kurzfristig ich meine die Union hat das
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil
erstritten das bundesverfassungs kriegt
hat einen Tag vor der
Bereinigungssitzung geurteilt also die
Bereinigungssitzung ist sozusagen die
Abschlusssitzung des Haushalts
Ausschusses was wir gesagt ein
bemerkenswerter Zeitpunkt ist und das
hat halt automatisch das Parlament in
allergrößte Schwierigkeiten bracht und
jetzt kommen wir natürlich sagen man
könnte sich die haushaltstricks auch
sparen Olaf Scholz wollte gerade sagen
das kann man nicht der Union in die
Schuhe schieben ne na ja ich meine es
bringt auch die Union sie haben ja
gerade Trick genau sie haben gerade
gesagt haushaltck es bringt auch die
Union in große Schwierigkeiten das
Urteil
das merkt ja auch wie der Regierende
Bürgermeister von Berlin drauf reagiert
hat der extrem erbost war und gesagt hat
wir müssen jetzt die Schuldenbremse
aussetzen wie die anderen
Ministerpräsidenten sch holin sch
Holstein NRW reagiert haben also es
bringt alle in erhebliche
Schwierigkeiten was waren Tricks man
kann es Tricks nennen man kann es
kreative Haushaltsführung nennen man
kann sie hab sie haben
gesagtiter sie haben gesagt für dieses
Chaos sollte sich der entschuldig ja
dazu stehe ich auch weil er sich
verzockt hat ja natürlich hat er sich
verzockt das ist doch offensichtlich
hätten sie gerne ein anderen Kanzler
aktuell ach wissen Sie zur Alternative
steht ja Friedrich märz und ich meine ja
oder Robert habck fällt dir nicht ein
Robert habeg sozusagen ist wenn man im
Moment die Stärke der Fraktionen im
Parlament anschaut sind wir nur die
drittstärkste Fraktion und der
Oppositionsführer ist Friedrich Merz und
wissen Sie ich habe das schon öfters
gesagt wenn in der Amp gar nichts mehr
geht und die Leute wirklich denken ey es
geht überhaupt nicht mehr weiter sagt
zuverlässig jemand Friedrich märz und
spätterestens dann einigt man sich
wieder weil halt offensichtlich ist dass
der halt deutlich ungeeigneter ist was
nahe zuu alle Aspekte angeht was Timing
der Kommunikation angeht was inhaltliche
Fragen angeht sind sie sich da ganz
sicher äh traurigerweise ja ich bin ja
ein großer Verfechter von schwarzgrün im
Grunde und mir sehr gewünscht dass bei
der letzten Wahl zu schwarzgrün gereicht
hätte was es leider nicht hat weil
sowohl wir uns als auch die Union sich
bisschen dumm angestellt haben im
Wahlkampf um sehr vorsichtig
auszudrücken aber das ist halt einfach
schlichtweg so und jetzt muss man mit
dem personalarbeiten das man hat
und ja das ist einfach so man muss mit
dem personalarbe anderen Kanzler her
heißt das nein also doch in der
momentanen Auswahl ist ja der Kanzler
der so zu sagen letztendlich ein paar
Dinge in meinen Augen anders machen muss
ist er ein guter Kanzler das wird sich
erst rückblickend am Ende zeigen aber
das zeigt sich immer erst rückblickend
wissen Sie wir dachten über sehr lange
Zeit dass Merkel dachte dieses Land
hervorragende Kanzlerin war und wenn man
sich anschaut jetzt rückblickend hat die
einen ganz schlimmen Scherbenhaufen
hinterlassen war sie es nicht nein sie
war es nicht nach allem was man jetzt
erkennen kann sie hat dieses Land in die
Abhängigkeit von China geführt sie hat
dieses Land nicht vernünftig investiert
wir sind bei Glasfaser ganz weit hinten
unsere Bundeswehr funktioniert nicht so
wie sie funktionieren sollte wir haben
keine funktionierende Rüstungsindustrie
wir waren überhaupt nicht vorbereitet
auf den Angriff Russlands auf die
Ukraine in der Energieversorgung hat man
uns in die völlige Abhängigkeit von
Russland getrieben das war alles eine
einzige Katastrophe jetzt im Rückblick
betrachtet und ich könnte mal vorstellen
dass im Rückblick Olaf Scholz deutlich
milder beurteilt wird als im Moment der
denn wenn man uns die Lage anschauen es
ist gelungen das Land ohne Blackouts
durch die Energiekrise zu führen obwohl
wir ca 50% von Russland abhängig ist es
ist gelungen den solarausbau wieder
anzuwerfen es ist gelungen an Haushalt
einigermaßen inriff zu kriegen es ist
gelungen auch unterwürken die Ukraine
einigermaßen zu unterstützen wir sind
inzwischen der zweitstärkste
Unterstützer der Ukraine das langt alles
nichts wir haben jetzt einen
vernünftigen Verteidigungsminister und
wir hab wir haben die Bauern auf der
Straße wir haben dieau auf der Strae und
nicht nur die Bauern sondern auch die
Lkwfahrer und die Gastronomen und das
halbe Land regt sich unvorstellbar auf
viele Leute regen sich auf deswegen aber
ich habe gerade aufgezählt was in dieser
schwierigen Lage alles gelungen ist
deshalb glaube ich dass man ihn im
Rückblick milder beurteilen wird als wie
wie gesagt bei Merkel die beurteilt man
jetzt deutlich härter als zu der Zeit
als sie regiert hat deswegen wä ich da
immer sehr vorsichtig mit so endgültigen
urteilen ich habe nicht angedeutet dass
wir anderen kanzleruch das waren sie nur
mal zur Erinnerung ne das habe ich doch
doch das hat ja jeder gehört Frau
weidenf ich habe nur gesagt dass März
sozusagen wenn gar nichts mehr geht in
der
Koalition zuverlässig dafür sorgt dass
man sich wieder einigt Frau Weidenfeld
noch mal diese Art und Weise zu
kommunizieren ich meine wenn man das so
hört da sitzen drei Menschen zusammen es
geht um entscheidende Dinge es geht um
eine Gruppe auch eine Berufsgruppe mit
der sich auch die eben zitierte Angela
Merkel nie angelegt hat sie sie nie
einer wirklich mit den Bauern angelegt
weil man wusste das ist
heikel kenne viele Landwirte viele Bauer
die hab sowas rebellisches in sich muss
man auch alles Wissen Psychologie spielt
auch eine große Rolle das ist so
m hab auch Gefühl für die Situation ja
ein Gefühl für die Situation ganz genau
heiß wie kann so etwas passieren und wie
kann man einen Minister vielleicht
schauen wirs das einmal kurz an Jim ötim
hier der auf offener Bühne wohlgemerkt
als Teil der
Regierung in die Situation gebracht wird
dass er sagen kann Freunde ich habe mir
das auch anders gewünscht also ich
Klammer auf der zuständige Minister ich
habe damit nichts zu tun wir hören
einmal kurz rein ich halte nichts von
den Streichungen in diesem Umfang und
ich habe auch früher nichts davon
gehalten im Gegenteil ich habe in der
Bundesregierung davor gewarnt
Agrardiesel und die KFZ Steuerregeln
abzuschaffen und in dieser Auffassung
hat sich bei mir nichts
geändert
Beil und der gleichzeitigen KFZ
Steuerbefreiung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Platz Liebe BerufskollegInnen Liebe
Berufskollegen wir kämpfen aber wir
kämpfen
fair Minister östem ist heute hier ich
habe ihm ein Respekt gezollt und dem
sollten wir ihn jetzt alle
entgegenbringen indem wir ihm zuhören
und ihn reden lassen ich bitte
darum ja aber am Ende hat er sich ja
durchgesetzt ne am Ende sozusagen W
wieder wieder einkassiert wurde es
zurückgenommen genauso wie er es
vorgeschlagen hat und es der ist doch
Teil des Kabinetts Herr Hofreiter ist
doch jetzt nicht irgend ich hab ja
vorher schon gesagt das war ein
Vorschlag der drei Spitzen die haben
sich daem gewissen Umfang verkalkuliert
der Landwirtschaftsminister hat sich am
Ende wieder verkalkuliert wieder
zurückgenommen Landwirtschaftsminister
hat sich durchgesetzt der hat dann sehr
sehr guten Job gemacht muss man ganz
klar sagen er hat sich getraut auch zu
sprechen
er hat sich in den Sturm gestellt und
hat am Ende einen guten Kompromiss
vorgeschlagen mit dem er in meinen Augen
jetzt alle vernünftig leben können
verehen Sie verstehen doch was das für
ein Gesichtsverlust ist also entweder
für den Minister oder für die anderen
drei es ist kein Gesichtsverlust für den
Minister nämlich hat sich am Ende
durchgesetzt okay für die anderen drei
dann mein Gott ich habe ja schon gesagt
dass das kommunikativ alles nicht toll
gelaufen ist das habe ich da schon
gesagt und wissen sie das würde ich mir
halt vom Kanzler wünschen dass er da ein
paar Dinge zukünftig anders macht das
ist das was ich meine mit ich wünsche
mir mehr Klarheit mehr Führungsstärke
und mehr Kommunikation in welcher Lage
wir sind und das leistet er halt nicht
und dadurch kommt diese Koalition obwohl
sie am Ende immer ganz vernünftige
Sachen macht immer wieder auf dem Weg
dahin in große Schwierigkeiten
frauidenfeld es ist glaube ich nicht nur
eine Frage der Kommunikation sondern es
ist ja auch eine Frage wie man etwas
anfängt und ich bin nicht der Auffassung
dass man sich nicht mit Landwirten
anlegen kann im Gegenteil ich finde eine
Regierung hatind selbsttochter eines
landwi ich bin selbsttochter eines
Landwirts ich glaube aber dass eine
Regierung und das Politi natürlich das
Recht haben Prioritäten zu setzen und
sich auch mit starken Lobbys anzu
anzulegen das ist das Recht von
Politikern und das ist auch vielleicht
in einer Lage in der wir jetzt sind die
Pflicht von Politikern was ich mich nur
Frage ist und Herr Hofreiter da da bin
ich eben wirklich ganz entgegengesetzt
ihrer Meinung es ist nicht nur eine
Frage wie ich etwas verkaufe sondern es
ist die Frage welche Politik ich nach
welchen Prioritäten mache und wenn ich
nicht in der Lage bin zu sagen erstens
dieses Land steht vor irsinnigen
Herausforderungen sie haben die Ukraine
genannt sie haben die Digitalisierung
genannt sie haben alle Themen genannt
mit denen wir zu tun habenemacht aber
sie sind nicht der Kanzler wenn ich
nicht in der Lage bin wenn ich nicht in
der Lage wenn ich nicht in der Lage bin
zu sagen aber das teile ich ja dass ich
da den Kanzler kritisiere da bin ich
absolut ihrer Meinung sind ihre Partei
ist Teil der Regierungskoalition wenn
ich nicht in der Lage bin zu sagen wir
haben Herausforderung diese
Herausforderungen können wir mit dem was
wir jetzt haben nicht bewältigen und
deshalb müssen wir einen neuen Anfang
einen neuen Start einen wir müssen
Wohlstandsverluste hinnehmen und wir
müssen die verhandeln und verteilen wenn
ich das nicht sagen kann dann kann ich
nicht aus dem Nichts kommen und sagen
heute die Landwirte morgen die
Wärmepumpe übermorgen das E-Auto und
wenn das dann immer noch nicht reicht
dann überlegen wir mal ob wir vielleicht
Karstadt weiter Subventionen geben
wollen oder so das geht nicht was gehen
was was funktioniert ist zu
sagen wir können das was wir bisher
gemacht haben nicht weitermachen und wir
müssen überlegen wie wir es finanzieren
und dann würde ich eben immer empfehlen
zu
sagen
375 Milliarden hat der Bundeshaushalt
das was gespart werden muss inind
ungefähr
3,84% von dem was das Budget ist und
dann sagt man eben okay dann muss eben
jeder diese 4% mitfinanzieren und dann
verhandelt man eben umgekehrt nicht
nimmt man einer Gruppe besonders viel
weg sondern die Gruppe die besonders
wenig weggommen haben will muss
begründen warum sie eine Ausnahme ist
das W wo ist jetzt der Widerspruch zu
meiner Aussage ich habe genau gesagt das
fordere ich Kanzler ein aber es ist
nicht nur der Kanzler sind die Grünen
auch die Vizekanzler der Grünen und der
FDP Sitz noch genauso im Boot und sie
sie können sozusagen die Führung aus dem
Kanzleramt nicht aus der zweiten Reihe
ersetzen das ist ein IR das bis jetzt
jeder Koalitionspartner gemacht hat das
geht einfach nicht und damit will ich
nicht sagen dass FDP und Grüne nicht
auch Fehler gemacht haben das will ich
überhaupt nicht sagen aber sie können
die Führung des Kanzleramts die Führung
des Kanzlers nicht durch ein Vizekanzler
nicht durch ein Finanzminister nicht
durch Fraktionsvorsitzende nicht durch
Parteivorsitzende ersetzen und ich teile
das absolut ich ich erwarte vom Kanzler
dass er deutlich macht wir leben in
extrem schwierigen Zeiten wir haben
Krieg in Europa wenn wir nicht handeln
wenn wir nicht klug handeln dann wird
sich dieser Krieg ausweiten weil Putin
weitere Länder angreifen muss und dafür
müssen wir alle etwas beitragen niemand
soll überproportional belastet werden
aber alle müssen etwas beitragen und
deswegen ist der Kompromiss wie er jetzt
am Ende rauskam für die Landwirtschaft
das sind ja sozusagen der größte Brocken
die Kfz-Steuer ist ja komplett weg und
das mit der Dieselsteuer wird jetzt
schrittweise gemacht ich glaub damit
könnt hätten alle leben können
insbesondere wenn man es vernünftig
begründen würde aber alles hat man nicht
gemacht